Woo, good shot, Sonta!
Going down.
That was distance right there. Thanks.
Was that your last shot
you hit it on? Second.
Second, huh?
Yeah. That was out there.
That was a good reach.
I felt like that was going to happen.
I wasn't quite sure and then.
Oh, yeah.
You know, once it starts going down
it's a good feeling.
That's a good boy.
Good boy!
Some dogs, they'll get a couple of goose.
They might get a little intimidated
because they're so big. Right.
Doesn't seem to back down from them.
No he's loving it out here right now.
I just want to make sure
to capitalize on this time
and get as many birds as we can.
Two guns is better than one. Yep.
Two of us shooting, double our chances.
I'm done hunting
when our freezers are full,
so we're going to get it done
and get as many geese as we can.
It's a hell of a journey today.
Feels good to reach the goal, you know.
Yeah cause the river threw
pretty much everything it could at me.
It's kind of just frozen at this point.
You know,
you always want things
to just work perfectly,
and you end up having to go through
hell and high water, but super grateful.
Ahh it feels nice.
So at this point,
I got to get this canoe hung
up, tied up high to one of these trees.
Come back in early fall,
bring the rifle, bring java
and we just float down the river.
I'm frustrated.
I can't find this buoy.
Where's that damn thing at?
It should be like, right in here.
I'm just gonna put a weight on here
in the bottom of it.
Drag this thing around.
If I can go crossways to the currant
maybe we can hook on to the line
if that buoy is like ten feet under.
The good
thing about it is the hooks
made out of wood, bone and spruce fruit.
We harvested the material
to make these hooks from nature.
They went back to nature.
Well, lets pull that rope in
and head back.
Alaska's tough.
Alaska took my halibut hook.
Alaska's taken some of my friends.
But Alaska is also given us everything
that we possibly need
to thrive and survive here.
It's an amazing place,
but you got to treat it with respect.
Well, I think it's done, Jeff.
This is what we live for.
That's a beauty.
There it is.
Mmm-hmm.
I'm hearing birds.
Better make that quick, buddy.
Look how low.
We'll grab our goose
and bring it into the blind with us,
and we can snack on it while we're
hunting. Let's get in there. All right.
We feel a lot
more secure when we have birds
heading to the freezer.
Just a great time to be around a
campfire a little bit,
do some hunting at the same time.
We enjoy eating what we're shooting.